i i have that vibe i
i'm one of the people who always winds
up hearing everyone's deepest darkest
secrets and problems
people believe they can confide in you
is that what you're saying yeah
why is that is that you do have a
certain voice doesn't she have a voice
ryan
put the mic up for god's sakes because
then we can't hear your voice
right she has this soothing voice do you
do a lot of voiceover work
interestingly not as much as you would
think
really because it's very unique i could
see you playing even a teenager of like
boy like kind of like a parker what's
the show
not parker lewis can't wait pinky
brewster punky bruce hunky brewster
you could you could do a funky brewster
monkey brewster
big mouth any of the fun stuff well you
did incredibles too i did
well how much fun was that the bet i
mean just the best
i also and you and you'll know the
feeling
i was at a lunch with friends
you know this was pre-pandemic when we
still ate inside and i was at a lunch
with friends
uh in venice and
my agent called and was like what is the
matter with you why have you not
responded to me today and i was like
what are you talking about first of all
i don't look at email so
what do you mean no i hate it i think
email is archaic and torturous and i
can't believe no one has developed a
better user interface but that's a
separate conversation
and so i i open the email and there's a
it's just a pdf
right and so i opened the pdf and it's a
letter on incredibles letterhead from
brad bird
asking me to play void and i
screamed at a pitch that i didn't know
my voice could make i thought i lost
that at like eight
that level of high you just let it go
it just happened and the whole
restaurant turned and i just went i'm so
sorry it's really good news
did everybody laugh or they were just no
some people were laughing and like a
couple people
when i left were like what was what
happened what's the news
but that's exciting though incredibles 2
you played void
yeah like i've done a lot of voiceover
work and did you find it
nerve-wracking were you acting with
other actors were you shooting by
yourself or
what did you do how'd you do it um i
didn't find it nerve-wracking
what i what was really interesting
and how fun as an adult to be really
surprised right
what was really interesting to me was
figuring out
how to create a sound to go along with
something that doesn't exist
oh yeah cause they hadn't showed you did
they show you any examples or like
little drawings
my animation wasn't done yet i had
drawings but
you know i was in the booth with brad
which is the most incredible thing i was
like please do edna
okay please do another voice okay okay
okay do this one now and he was like
we're here to record you
ma'am um but it was really
fun to get to play with a writer
director of that caliber
and and also to feel free enough in the
room when he'd say
okay you're gonna jump uh you know from
the stoop to the sidewalk
off of let's say six stairs you gotta
land we need the sound of you landing
okay fine
okay but what happens when you jump off
a hundred story building and land i have
no idea what that sounds like
right so we had to just come up with
things and and it was fun in moments
what's the sound effect for jumping off
the stoop
just the small version i mean you how
would you land
i'm going to ask you yeah
you know a little breath because you get
the wind slightly knocked out
try it oh you just coughed that sounded
like a cough
that didn't sound good when was your
last negative pcr